Well, this distance would be 12 units, great thinking if you found it. Since to
find this vertical distance, we figured out how far we climbed on the y axis.
We went from y equals 3, up 5 units to y equals 8. That's how we knew that this
distance was 5. So to find the horizontal distance. We're going to start at x
equals negative 7, this x value, and run all the way to the right, to x equals
positive 5, this x value. So, the horizontal distance between these two points
would be from negative 7 to positive 5. That would be a total distance of 12
units. You can find this distance by counting the spaces from negative 7 to
positive 5. Or you can subtract the 2 numbers, and make sure to take the
absolute value, so you get a positive number in the end. Here I just did 5
minus negative 7, which equals positive 12. If you would've subtracted 5 from
negative 7, you would've gotten negative 12. So you would've had to take the
absolute value. So that way you get a positive distance, or just 12.